Wonder Woman has arrived in theaters and
much to the disappointment of comic
conscious nerds it went incredibly light
on the easter eggs sure we were treated
to an island full of Amazon's that
seemed pretty faithful to their comic
counterparts but the film didn't have a
single inexplicable time-traveling flash
cameo what's a wonder nerd to do let's
roll up our sleeves and see what secret
DC references we were able to find
between the frames of Wonder Woman and
of course super spoilers ahead we all
scream because it's a comic book movie
Wonder Woman borrowed a huge chunk of
its content from you know comic books
just in a very general sense however
eagle-eyed readers of DC Comics new 52
version of Justice League we're quick to
spot a story beat cribbed directly from
the comic pages in the first few pages
of Justice League number three Princess
Diana has pretty much the same
conversation with an ice cream vendor as
she does in the film though the comic
presents a more modern setting the story
quickly diverges however as modern Diana
as quickly attacked by parrot demons
from another planet while movie Diana
remains hell-bent on hunting down Ares
the scene gets another adaptation in the
animated feature Justice League war
further cementing the fact that despite
having a pretty good grasp on pleasure
Amazon's don't have anything on humans
they have an isolated island paradise
but we have Ben and Jerry's point
mortals four-eyes Wonder Woman doesn't
have a very extensive history on screen
compared to some of her contemporaries
butter 1975 TV show is a thing of legend
mostly because it was straight-up goofy
fun what kind of Amazonian magic does it
take to spin around to change your
clothes we never found out but plenty of
people got dizzy trying notably 1975's
Wonder Woman employed the unrealistic
trope that if you wear a pair of glasses
you're completely unrecognizable is the
same human you are without your glasses
so when the cinematic Wonder Woman pops
on a pair of specs as part of her
disguise to blend in with lowly humans
it's quickly called out by Etta candy as
being completely ridiculous
because honestly it's about time someone
did official business because Bruce
Wayne is the richest man in the world he
can afford to send armored cars anywhere
he wants even if they just contain a
single photograph made while the rest of
the 99% just has to settle for the post
office losing their birthday presents in
the black hole that is New Jersey still
when Bruce sends around his Wayne
Mobile's you'd think he'd be a little
more subtle about the fact that he's the
guy at stumbling a group of superhumans
called the Justice League but know when
you're Wayne's level of rich
you spring for vanity plates and you
make sure those plates have the initials
of your super-secret team on them having
the letters JL lead off your armored
cars the license plate is real subtle
Bruce what does your other car say I'm
Batman
God killer so as we learn by the end of
the movie it turns out to the magical
God killer sword can actually kill God
and just like in the after-school
specials of your the power to kick some
godly butt was inside Diana all along as
far as DC Comics is concerned that God
killers sword is generally the domain of
the mercenary villain known as
Deathstroke the Terminator the far too
powerful weapon was crafted by one god
to kill another and was given to Earth's
greatest assassin so while it's clear
that Wonder Woman's big screen sword
wasn't the real deal there are rumblings
of Deathstroke appearing in the DC EU
could we get a look at the real god
Killer sword in the future Amazon Prime
while it's not really an easter egg DC
went all out in including Princess
Diana's many many friends and relatives
inste mascara while some were named on
screen a handful are only mentioned in
the credits every single one of these
Amazon's has had a few comic pages
dedicated to them even if most of them
are largely interchangeable warrior
women but maybe we'll see a couple of
them again in Wonder Woman - it's a
miracle there's not a whole lot of
information about that mystery gas
general ludendorf was snorting in order
to Hulk out but DC Comics is a pretty
weird history of its heroes and villains
taking strange substances to perform
superhuman tasks
one early example of this appeared in
1940 under the name moralo a miracle
vitamin that enabled a Golden Age hero
Power Man to do heroic things 460
action-packed minutes while Morocco was
developed for positive purposes it
eventually fell into the wrong hands and
became a substance that Batman fans will
be very familiar with venom whether or
not doctor poisons power up gas will
eventually find its way into the
bubbling tubes of the supervillain Bane
is anyone's guess but the foundations
have been laid to break the back of
batfleck thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check all this cool stuff
we know you love to
[Music]